texans general manager meeting with
reporters yesterday at a golf tournament
down in houston they have a strange
situation
at quarterback you got to sean watson
and
deshawn watson
i say at the earliest he shows up just
before training camp
anticipating that he would be placed on
the commissioner exempt list and paid
for the year to not play for the texans
either way the idea of him wearing a
texans helmet i think is slim at this
point then they've got tyrod taylor who
they signed as a free agent for about
what 10 12 million dollars for this year
he's the de facto starter for now then
they trade for ryan finley the guy who
came in and beat the steelers on monday
night last year showed some some flashes
of ability he adds to the depth chart
and then they use
a third round pick on davis mills the
quarterback out of stanford the guy that
was the betting favorite
to be the sixth quarterback taken he
ends up being the eighth quarterback
taken in the draft after kyle trask then
kellen and obviously the first five and
uh regarded by coach david cully as the
steal of the draft so they've got four
guys you know they say if you have two
quarterbacks you don't have any i don't
know what it means when you have four
but they're going to have options
and they're going to have to figure out
as cesario said through this process
which guy is going to be we can take
watson off the table even though he's on
the roster but between taylor and finley
and mills
one of those guys is going to be the
starter week one yeah and at this point
i don't think they know i don't think
anyone else knows yeah no i mean i i
would bet on tyrod taylor with the
amount of money they gave him he's the
only one with like real experience
you're right finley you know had a
moment last year showed some like
progress you know it was a little rough
for him the year before that when he
played davis mills see the good thing is
is with like a guy like davis mills here
so they could start ty rod taylor and
now you have finley who yes we've shown
that can be a little bit of a backup and
win your game if you need be but i think
that's also what davis mills is let
alone maybe something for the future
like maybe that guy but davis mills was
one of the most if not the most he was
he was really probably only behind mac
jones it's probably like being polished
nfl reads in the pocket really playing
the position to like the true pocket
form type of guy that's what he is davis
mills and because of that he's a little
bit maybe more mature than some of the
you know
other rookie quarterbacks i mean on the
field and what he's experienced and all
that to where i think he can you know
run a pro offense and not have a huge
learning curve here you know early on in
his career because of what he did in
stanford so it's like a double whammy
with that pick maybe we got our starter
for the future in davis mills i don't
think he's that i'll say that you know i
think he's a really awesome
high-end backup quarterback for the most
of his career but hopefully he proves me
wrong but at the very least yeah you
take a shot in the dark that could be
the future and hey he's a polished
rookie who can
we we can win games and make do if tyrod
did get hurt early in the year and we
got to throw somebody in there
we need to talk to the folks at points
bet about the over under as to when
tyrod taylor
is not available to play due to dr
needle injury dr needle whatever the
case may be we've seen this movie with
tyrod taylor seriously he's the starter
there's a rookie at some point he yields
to the rookie now it's not as
preordained this year as it was in 2018
when he was with the browns and it was
baker mayfield or last year when he was
with the chargers and it was justin
herbert even though anthony lynn coach
at the chargers at the time was saying
to anyone who would listen
justin herbert's not playing justin
herbert's not playing justin herbert's
not playing enter dr needle and there
goes tyrod taylor again so i agree with
you he'll probably start the season i
just wonder if by halloween he'll still
be the quarterback for the houston
texans another thing on mills yeah
nothing on mills
and and this was the question that was
posed to casario yesterday
uh stanford head coach david shaw said
that davis mills is one of the steals of
the draft what do you think about that
said caserio i'm not a draft expert i
have a lot of respect for david shaw so
you can talk to david about what he
thinks we're just glad that we have
players that we have in the building i
look i a general manager is a draft
expert i i guess he was probably trying
to be funny or deflected but
i'd like to think most fans would look
at the 32 general managers in the nfl
and say there's the draft experts who
have skin in the game yeah none of the
other ones
all the other ones are just talk you
better be a draft expert if you're going
to be if you're going to be putting in
the pics for an nfl team well i'll say
it for him he is a draft expert he is he
clear he classifies that but you know
that's a tricky thing to say you know if
you're a gm and you say oh well i'm a
i'm a draft expert too the first time
you mess up on a draft pick everyone's
all this idiot oh let's start a meme on
him he said he's a draft expert he
picked this guy so it is like in this
era right now it's hard to say stuff
like that at times you know and he's
probably talking about like
it really what i took it more though if
anything is just like he's not a draft
expert as far as the history of the
draft and who's the biggest steal ever i
i really don't know but either way
there was there was people on both sides
of the fence with davis mills and
obviously the texans really believe in
him
the fact that they put his name on the
card and it happened quickly when it
went yes uh kyle trask and then
right and then boom you've got you've
got davis mills i think they realized if
we're gonna jump we better jump now and
and look to the extent that mills was
favored to go before trask and mond
hey the texans may have been one of
those teams that regarded mills is
better and and that they view it as a
gift that mills slipped through the
cracks to them and now they can start to
build something for the future a future
that undoubtedly will not include desean
watson being on the field however his
situation works out continues to be
incredibly quiet
we are
a couple of weeks into this period of
the lawyers saying not a word after this
non-stop rapid fire pointing fingers
social media press releases public uh
statements it it tells me something's
going on aimed at trying to resolve it
that's the only explanation at this
point they're trying to resolve these
cases so deshaun watson can continue his
football career and he'll be potentially
traded to someone before training camp
opens
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports